هيبقى ابدا لعل معك مازن فيما يتعلق ان
كان هناك من الجهه اللبنانيه ما يؤكد او
يوضح ما جرى ما يقول الجانب الاسرائيلي
بانه صاروخ اطلق من الجانب اللبناني
في الواقع عبد القادر بالفعل قبل نحو اكثر
من نصف ساعه من الان اطلق صاروخ من جنوب
مدينه صور الساحليه عند مقربه من منطقه
الناقوره الحدوديه مع اسرائيل وبالتالي
اطلق الصاروخ الاول من تلك المنطقه التي
تعرف بمنطقه القليله وايضا منذ نحو عشر
دقائق سجل
سجلت اصوات اطلاق صواريخ اضافيه من نفس
المنطقه التي اطلق منها الصاروخ الاول
وبالتالي هذا الموقع الذي تم اطلاق
الصواريخ منه وموقع معتاد الشهر في العام
الماضي وفي نفس الشهر في ابريل ايضا اطلق
من تلك المنطقه التي هي قريبه الى حد ما
من مخيم الراشدين للاجئين الفلسطينيين
اطلقت دفعه من الصواريخ وهي غالبا ما كانت
تطلق باتجاه الداخل الاسرائيلي عندما يكون
هنالك تطورات معينه ترتبط بالساحه
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي يمكن وفقه قراءه
اوليه للمعطيات الوارده من جنوب لبنان بان
المنطقه التي اطلقت منها الصواريخ لها
دلاله واضحه لحيث الى حيث من هو الطرف
الذي اطلق هذه الصواريخ نحن لا نتحدث عن
منطقه عمل مباشر لحزب الله ولكنها اقرب
الى المخيمات الفلسطينيه وبالتالي ضمن هذا
السياق حتى هذه اللحظه يقرا ما حصل في
جنوب لبنان خلال الساعه الماضيه بوصفه الى
حتى هذه اللحظه بانه محصور ضمن اطار
عمليات كانت حصلت سابقا من قبل منظمات
فلسطينيه عندما كان يتعرض المصلون في
القدس وفي الاقصى الى تدخل من قبل الجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كان يحصل هنالك بعض
ردات الفعل من على سبيل المثال اطلاق هذه
الصواريخ باتجاه العمق ووصولا الى نهارين
عمليا ضمن هذه القراءه يتم الان فهم ما
يحصل من تطوراته وما حصل من تطورات خلال
الساعه الماضيه ولكن بطبي كما اعتدنا عبد
القادر في مناسبات سابقه
ارتبطت باطلاق صواريخ من جنوب لبنان فان
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كانت غالبا ما
تطلق نيرانا مدفعيتها باتجاه مناطق مفتوحه
ترتبط بالسهول التي تطلق منها هذه
الصواريخ وبالتالي قبل دقائق كان هنالك
معطيات عن ان المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
استهدفت منطقه مفتوحه جنوبي لبنان عند
المنطقه الفاصله الحدوديه بني راني
مدفعيتها وضمن هذا السياق حتى هذه اللحظه
قوات اليونيفر لم تعطي اي تقرير واضح حول
ملابسات وتفاصيل العمليه التي شهدناها
خلال هذه الساعه الماضيه وايضا الجيش
اللباني هو يتريث في اصدار بيان واضح حول
ملابسات القضيه ولكن وفق معطيات ملصقات من
الميدان مباشره فان عمليه اطلاق الصواريخ
كانت حتى الان من محيط المخيم الفلسطيني
وبالتالي هنالك من يقول ب هذا الامر هو
تكرار لسانوريوهات سابقه كنا قد شهدناها
ليس فقط في ابريل من العام الماضي ولكن
خلال السنوات الماضيه عندما كانت تحتدم
المواجهه في الساحه الفلسطينيه مع قوات
الاحتلال في الداخل الفلسطيني فانه غالبا
ما كانت الفصائل الفلسطينيه تطلق صواريخها
باتجاه الداخل الاسرائيلي في محاوله منها
لبعثه رسائل تؤكد على ان هنالك وحده
للساحات وحده متكامله وانه لا يمكن
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان يستمر بما يقوم به
على مستوى داخل الفلسطيني بطبيعه الحال
هنا عبد القادر لا بد من التذكير والحديث
عن ان المعادلات معادلات الردع التي كانت
قد ارسلت سابقا والتي يلتزم بها حزب الله
وايضا الجانب الاسرائيلي بعد حرب عام 2006
وايضا خلال السنوات الماضيه لم يتم خرقها
على مستوى واسع وبالتالي هذه العمليات
الموضوعيه لناحيه اطلاق صواريخ وايضا من
نوع كاتيوشا وهي صواريخ نوعا ما يمكن
القول بان صواريخ قديمه بدائيه
المدى الجغرافي والحيز الذي يمكن ان تصيبه
هو محدود وبالتالي ضمن هذا السياق اطلاق
صاروخ ورد اسرائيلي موضوعي هذا ما كنا
نشهده خلال الفترات السابقه